- Have you met Nick?
Have y'all met before?
- Just met.
- Nice to meet you.
- Good to see you.
- [Kelly] Just met.
- New father.
- A new father!
- Congratulations.
- Thank you.
- I have four year old twins.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh!
- Oh, beautiful.
- Yeah. Yeah
- Girls or boys?
- Girl and a boy.
- Oh, that's perfect!
- They're great. They're beautiful. Yeah.
- Yeah. Oh. They both will give
you different kinds of hell,
just so you know.
But they'll also both
love you differently.
- [Robert] But they'll all give me hell.
- But they'll all give you hell
but they'll both love you
in different ways too, so,
and I like you have a girl
and a boy, that's nice.
- I do.
- That's nice.
- Haven and Hudson
- Haven and Hudson! What perfect names.
- Yeah. So I named her Haven
because she's a little bit of heaven.
- Aww. You're cute.
- I know.
And then people were like,
why'd you name him Hudson?
I was like... the river.
- So I named my daughter
river and people were like,
what's the meaning?
I'm like, oh, we live on a river.
I was like, and we were both looking out
and we're like, River's a cool name.
And, but it's kind of a rockstar name.
Hudson's cool.
- Well, it is cool,
but I didn't put a lot of thought into it.
- Hudson and hey, well
don't tell him that.
There's therapy in the future.
He didn't care about my name.
I have to ask you about the ice thing.
Had you ever done anything
like that before? The ice bath?
- No. No. It was so cold.
- I didn't know if you
played sports, Graham,
because I feel like in sports, people do.
Look at your face!
Oh my God. Have you ever done that?
- I have one in my house.
Not this brand, but we have a cold plunge.
- Give me your address.
Give me your address,
I'll send it to you.
- You send me one of these?
- Yes.
- Amazing.
- Yeah.
- Wait, so they're supposed
to be really good for you.
- [Robert] They're incredible.
- They're really good for your health.
- [Nick] Yeah.
- Did you, like I found once I was in it,
like I woke up like that. It was amazing.
- [Kelly] Of course you do!
- And you also feel
like you can't breathe.
- [Robert] Right.
- And like all of your
insides are shriveling up,
but other than that, it's great.
- Oh, you know what? Sign me up, Nick.
That sounds like a hell of a party.
- Did you feel really rejuvenated?
- I did. Yeah. I felt rejuvenated.
And I do it probably once a week
because it's really good for inflammation.
- [Kelly] It is.
- And you know, any nights
that get away from you,
you have one too many glasses of wine.
- [Kelly] What?
- It's good for that.
- Pop in there, you're fine.
- You're the one who sends people tequila,
that's your problem.
It's good.
- Have you ever done it?
- I have. I have done it once
as a like, and for like a second.
Like when you're in high school,
I jumped in one of like
the player's ice baths.
I was like, no, but then
I watched this whole thing
on how good that is for
your body, your heart.
Like, there's so many
things that that's good for.
And I don't know, I've never done it,
but I've always wanted one.
But then I thought, am I that LA tool
that's like I have an ice bath in my,
haha I just called you a tool!
- Am I an LA tool?
- I didn't want to say it! Wow.
- Wow. That's two, Kelly.
- That's two! Fake, Colin Hanks.
Well, congrats on getting picked up.
- [Robert] Thank you.
- It's the 14th season? 14?
- 14th season, yeah.
- [Kelly] That's amazing.
It's hard to last that long
with a show. That's amazing.
- [Robert] Yeah.
- So why do you, and by the way,
I love that Cuban was in the corner
while you were in that ice bath.
Oh, just get in there.
And I'm like, hey, real
easy from the cheap seats.
You're like not in the ice bath.
- Cuban's like that friend you have
who never does anything, but always--
- [Kelly] But gives you crap about yeah!
- Yeah! Yeah. Oh, I'd do that!
And I'm like do it. Na.
- Yeah. I was like, by the
way, I had to bring that up.
So wait, so why do you think
the show is so successful?
People love it.
- I think because we are
the mirror to America.
I think anything is possible.
When people come out on our show,
I mean, we've been filming for 14 years.
- Yeah.
- And we're all busy and
we're all doing other things,
but when those doors open
and somebody comes out.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It's their opportunity
to change their life.
And as melodramatic as it sounds,
America is about possibility.
And when those people come out, I mean,
Kelly, you see it in their eyes.
Like, it completely changes their lives.
And I love that about the show.
- That's so cool.
And the fact you get to
be able to help people
to accomplish that.
- We help a lot of people.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And we teach people
how to start a business
because you know, how
many people in America
know somebody who started a business?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And not everybody can
go to a fancy school
and everybody wants to start a business.
Because if you can control yourself
and know how business works,
you'll never be poor in life.
- Yeah. It's, I'm not good
at that kind of thing.
I'm like all passion and creativity.
Like it's so good that
people like you exist.
So what's the one pitch
though that you've heard
that still amazes you?
- The, my favorite pitch is
something called Tipsy Elves.
- Tipsy Elves, I'm in.
- [Robert] Yeah.
- Cheers. Oh, they took my drink.
They took my drink. Well, that was rude.
- I didn't get it. I didn't get a drink.
- I know, that's rude.
Wait, my show is so rude.
- But they came out and
one guy was a lawyer
and one guy was a dentist,
and they hated being a lawyer and dentist.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- They were a little bit older
and they decided one day
we're gonna start a business.
Had no experience, no background.
They Googled what's a
good business to start.
And they found--
- [Kelly] What?
- I'm not making this up,
they found Christmas sweaters.
- Yeah.
- Right, ugly Christmas sweaters.
So they said, how do we stand out
in the ugly Christmas sweater market?
Inappropriate ugly Christmas sweaters.
- [Kelly] I'm in.
- Yeah. So they come out.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- All the sharks are out
and I'm like, why am I here?
This is horrible.
And then I find out they
have $600,000 in sales.
They sell them online, bring them in.
And I like, I think I gave them--
- Because people like me exist.
- I think I gave them
$200,000 for 20 or 25%.
And that was many seasons ago.
And we'll do $100,000,000 this year.
- What?
- Yeah. Yeah. There's a
lot of people like you!
- There are lot of me out there!
Do you know what's happening
in the world right now?
They're all watching this going,
why didn't I think of that?
Like, I could have done
that. That's amazing.
- Those are the best ideas.
- Oh my God! It's so great.
Well, Robert has teamed up
with his most successful
"Shark Tank" investment,
Tipsy Elves, to bring
you a little surprise.
Tipsy Elves makes the world's
most outrageous apparel,
I love it, to make your life more fun.
And today, each of you
are getting $100 gift card
at Tipsy Elves.
So we can all be inappropriate together.